voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que les pouvoirs du démon mélange
devienne [ __ ] [ __ ] c'est squeeze
aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur devil may
cry tout fraîchement sorti mercredi
dernier
disponible sur xbox ps3 et pc dans une
semaine je crois d'alzheimer ça c'est
cool ça sur pc développé par capcom
ninja theory pardon et édité par capcom
excusez moi alors donc je vais faire la
mission tout en vous expliquant un petit
peu le jeu alors capcom sega capcom oui
c'est une boîte qui développe des jeux
tout comme une île et beast of the troll
nom de l'umac reiss est un beat them all
tout fraîchement sorti donc comme je
disais est alors déjà je vais vous dire
un truc c'est que moi les beat them all
j'en ai joué qu'à 1 c'était un jeu sur
le xbox live arcade c'est le dispatcheur
qu d'arc fût m'a fait acheter et j'étais
ultra mais vraiment ultra intéressé par
comment ça s'appelait par god of war sur
ps3 sauf que je n'ai que l'ex bloc donc
je me suis dit ensuite
donc je me suis dit [ __ ] alors là
c'est un beat them all en plus il a
l'air de cartonner il me le faut
absolument je les achetais et
honnêtement au je fais pas cette vidéo
pour rien je vais vous expliquer un
petit peu de gens détails
alors là actuellement on doit être le
jeu est constitué de plusieurs stages
donc démission c'est pas du de
l'exploration libre ou quoi anoh
nettement dont arles 1 faute 1 limite
c'est bien comme ça et il ya vingt stage
au cours du jeu ça doit être le
troisième je dirais ouais le troisième
je fais quoi là je vais vous achever la
hausse très bien ah non à la parfait
donc c'est le troisième stage sur 20 e
donc c'est un beat them all c'est à dire
un jeu où vous défoncer tout exactement
comme lâché en train de faire comme ça
un peu c'est à dire c'est un peu pour un
genre buzz feu et ont défoncé un peu
tout dans le tas comme ça va amener
coups de hache et hop hop hop hop on
tire une petite balle en l'air enfin
bref que des trucs du genre et surtout
on fait peur et salo et surtout
c'est bien par exemple qu'on revenait
d'une journée cours de merde que prend
vous en fais chier et labo vous défouler
un peu sur devil may cry et ça déchire
alors au niveau du jeu au niveau de
l'histoire plus précisément c'est simple
dans tes donc c'est le personnage qu'on
a actuellement en train de jouer qui est
le héros du jeu donc c'est un mec
vraiment qu'à vachement lucile qui est
un beau gosse un beau gosse purin faut
l'admettre et a tenté c'est donc le
héros du jeu et il est en fait me ange
mi démon c'est à dire qu'il est né son
père est un démon et sa mère est un ange
est donc lui ça donne un hybride voilà
tout homme
certains des fois faut se concentrer
dans le jeu je vous jure au niveau 1 au
niveau de l'histoire à c'est très simple
dans tes donc je retrouve dans le monde
des vivants dans le monde comme nous
l'avons actuellement et il peut passer
dans le monde des larmes c'est à dire
dans le monde où il ya plein de démo
donc des fois oui il peut passer d'un
monde à l'autre et à bab n'est ce pas
glacé par un parent ou un vilain des
mots comme celui ci d'ailleurs j'étais
en train de me défoncer évidemment il
lui pète le q1 courage bordel de fait
qui pète un câble et may cry
tiens tiens bon bref tout ça pour vous
dire que voilà c'est l'histoire alors en
fait dans tes va ensuite retrouvé son
frère jumeau son frère jumeau qui
s'appelle faire gilles donc son frère
jumeau lui va en fait le dire écoute mon
frère mon frère jumeau il faut qu'on
sauve le monde des réelles des démons
parce que sinon on est dans la merde et
qui s'est tu veux essayer de contrôler
ce monde c'est en fait un espèce de gros
chauffe tout moi je manquais cas
vraiment énormément de poids dans la
société je paie c'est un peu son dieu
parce que la winery un espèce de gros
méchants chose qui a vraiment énormément
de poids dans la société qui s'appelle
moon gone 12 donc jeu
du latin monde et vu ça veut dire
maîtrisait bien ce n'est quand même pas
ce que je vous dis ses rangs notamment
du deal est donc ce grand vide à mon 12
veut dominer le monde et la cedh en
question traite qui vont essayer de bien
empêcher alors pour cela et pour moi
parce que tu as mais il est vachement
cher le mythe casse toi
pour cela il ya aussi une voyante
peuvent avoir sur mon appareil dans
cette mission c'est elle qui nous a
emmenés actuellement dans cette mission
qui s'appelle cette voyante qui
s'appelle vidéo à 4 voilà je suis je me
suis un max et 4 et qui donc elle ne
peut pas passer d'un monde à l'autre
mais peut voir dans le monde des
habitants le gros qui peut voir dans le
monde des larmes tout simplement et qui
va guider dans tes à travers sa quête
pour un peu ma sauver le monde tout
simplement
alors au début dans tes pour savoir que
c'est un perso un peu jean foutisme
genre je m'en fous un peu de tout mais
au final il va un peu ralliée à la cause
de son frère voit quand même merci
députés donc rares d'encaisser un peu
cool quoi parce que je veux juste sauvé
le monde on sait que tu en a rien à
[ __ ] parce que tu as un peu la classe
c'est clair mais bon un moment il faut
quand même faire des choses sans penser
qu'à soi mon cher nantais alors voilà
donc là on est actuellement dans le
monde des limbes vous l'aurez deviné un
sinon y'a pas vraiment des gens comme ça
dans notre monde à nous à moins à moins
que quoique y en a qui sont qui ont des
têtes 6% - et donc on doit de but
évidemment alors là le but de la mission
on est sous l'entrepôt d'une boisson
brèche vais pas vous foyen comme ça je
vous laisserai découvrir cette jeu vous
intéresse plus tôt c'est plus
intelligent que lui déclaré et alors
dans cette démo de l'avantagé c'est
qu'on peut passer à faire le truc un peu
fou fou c'est que ce sont en fait le but
du jeu est de faire le plus de points
possible comment faire des pointes à me
sois laissé passer ce gros porc à [ __ ]
mais les casses toi la tiare avec tes
grosses fesses de 2,2 regarde rien et
moi avons faisait jamais vu des fêtes
que ces grosses et moi non plus hein
il fait peur il fait peur donc on peut
passer d'une arme à l'aube alors
actuellement je n'ai bien évidemment pas
débloquée et hervé et bien évidemment
pas débloquer toutes les armes du jeu
on a largement plus que ça j'ai osiris
aux lycées battant juste après la
cinématique vous allez c'est une faux
comme ça donc on peut passer d'une arme
à l'automne appuyant sur les gâchettes 1
pour info vous allez c'est une faute
donc c'est un truc moi j'ai toujours eu
un faible pour ce genre d'armes c'est
vraiment s'il échoue donc c'est une
fausse condé concon mais quand on appuie
sur la gâchette de gauche ensuite on est
nash qui s'appellera je sais plus il y
risque et je suis comme ça non je sais
plusieurs de bêtises qu'on est bleu
qu'on combat en appuyant sur la touche
de droite et ensuite on a des pistolets
qu'on a tout simplement en appuyant sur
x et notre ep 1 évidemment alors sont à
notre disposition de graffin l'un pour
hors jeu juste acheté un petit truc pour
regagner parce que là je me suis quand
même fait défoncer [ __ ] ils m'ont
défoncer tout simplement à la bombe a eu
tous avaient rebaptisé start objets
restant restaure toute la vie alors
métier ça va par là et je commente en
même temps c'est un peu chaud de se
concentrer pour sortir des bottes de
cowboy tout on a aussi donc de grappins
donc le grappin avec osiris qui permet
d'aller vers l'ennemi et le grappin avec
la hache qui permet d'attirer un ennemi
tout simplement alors au niveau du
gameplay
honnêtement c'est super chaud je suis
pas habitué du tous vos merveilleux bon
je suis au-dessus à six mois pour les
brouilles tools monkey des bruits de
coups dans sa vidéo ses coûts au niveau
du gameplay je disais on peut donc
enchaîné quand on tape par exemple à
l'épée ensuite à la faut en même temps à
ma là je peux pas rencontrer à l'épée je
vous montrais juste après pour chaque
fois qu'on voit des ennemis on peut donc
passer d'une arme à l'otan plein combo
envoyer les ennemis en l'air avec cetera
et cetera et c est ça donne un mélange
par exemple hp aux gammes fui à la faute
je vais mettre à coups de hache des
incultes h 20 il ya vraiment pas de
souci sur ça on varie un peu finger in
the nose d'une arme à l'automne chaud
pas au pistolet et pph non non non non
bon heureusement canton dans le vide
c'est pas très pénalisant mais bien la
[ __ ] mais c'est chiant lui donc voilà
ça à peu près tout pour le gameplay
ensuite il ya un petit aspect rpg qui
m'a vachement plus d'enjeu bon je vais
vous en parler un petit peu après on va
essayer de se concentrer juste d'avancer
de plateforme en plateforme puis même
regarder un peu comme comme c'est joli
par exemple juste ça j'ai trouvé ça
super but quand j'ai découvert une foule
c'est assez sympa alors le seul défaut
dangereux pour moi honnêtement bon j'ai
après c'est clair que moi je découvre la
licence ea et les beat them all même
carrément pas seulement licence que
j'écoute c'est même le type beat them
all le fruitier avec un jeu vraiment
bien foutu ou quoi avec ce devil may cry
mais le seul petit défaut c'est la
caméra qui se bougent manuellement bon
j'ai découvert comme il ya trois minutes
qu'on peut la botte que si par exemple
la j'appuie sur le bad cops à le tourner
vers le verlan temps' et alors là je
dois me concentrer parce que ça va être
assez chaud à la glace et son pote les
débiles or au génial génial vous êtes
comment utiliser la taxe d'un autre oeil
ces autos glace et c'est aussi ma mère
alors effectivement on fait remarquer là
vous devez vous demander mais pourquoi
utilise la hache pour tuer le rouge et
la peau pour tuer le dit lin bleu parce
que des fois ya des ennemis qui sont
sensibles qui avec certaines armes et
pas avec tout
par exemple à le bonhomme blessant six
pieds que la fouille madame rouge
qu'avec la hache c'est pour ça que j'ai
utilisé les armes une par une pour tuer
les 2e et puis et puis voilà donc je
disais au niveau du la caméra voilà
c'est un peu le seul petit truc du jeu
donc évidemment la change avec le pad de
droite et où là où il ya du monde
apparemment où il ya du monde va pas
faire des gros combos de porc bim je
t'envoie l'herbe and famous de tabac
mais j'attire tous les autres en l'air
regardez objat et les toutes premières
maintenant et là on des ponts tout le
monde ou tom van damme et bam bam sait
vraiment mais c'est excellent et voyez
je peux vous dire je n'avais jamais joué
les guides et mbaye et c'est assez fun
alors la dante et va devoir donc avant
ses bénéfices dans une sage du croisy
pas tout sourire
pour empêcher les gens s'en fait le
grand vide à moundou ce que je vous ai
dit le chauffe pour les le monde
c'est un démon immortel lui 1 et les
dominantes elles peuvent être tués
uniquement pour les hybrides comme dante
et son frère jumeau c'est d'ailleurs il
y en a que deux il ya que le réseau
secondaire c'est à dire parler mis en
jeu et mi-démon sommes donc seul vilain
ils distribuent des boissons dans la
ville est en fait ces boissons en bossa
lobotomise un peu les gens savent bien à
sable et un peu des zombies quoi
mentalement ils sont présents des greens
ils réagissent plus 3 rien quoi et c'est
une boisson ultra mauvaise pour la santé
mais mehmood ça tellement de pouvoir en
fait c'est pas un pouce de quoi donc
c'est comme si actuellement on sortait
un produit chez ba qui vous fait gagner
3000 kcal par semaine par exemple et eco
vous dit non et qu'on me dise pas
redondant si génial c'est fait avec
essentiellement de l'eau la paye du sud
dedans alors que en gros il ya près
toutes les équipes de l'impasse contient
donc voilà ah bon je néglige pas le
coquin gens moi tout le temps j'adore ça
et je m'en fous un peu de ce qu'on peut
dire dessus tout comme dangereux ils
s'en foutent de sa lobotomise ou kouassi
surtout trouver sa voie
bref je dis pas que je divague une
valeur proche de philosophie ma foi je
ne sais même plus ce que je disais on
prend là c'est tellement fort tellement
bien
oh là là franchement j'adore j'adore
c'est vraiment mieux
incroyable un gameplay vraiment fou up
tak tak répond je suis concentré limpide
et alors
puis en tournée on va cette source au
line up on va envoyer en l'air nouvelle
fois ont valu en l'air tac tac on lâche
pas encore été super longtemps en l'air
c'est ça aussi un commando du jeu up sur
la hache pour est un sorcier vaudou
traîné par terre devant l'air airs de
défonce à la hache la hache c'est
vraiment le truc eu un peu ce quoi genre
vraiment trop loin pour les a tous eu
voilà au cube m3 aussi yes d'accord sans
titre vous tirer dessus avant que ça
nous c nous vient de succéder à fillon
excellent de défonce donc vous aurez
remarqué quand je tue les ennemis en bas
à droite à un truc sympa du jeu c'est je
veux en venir c'est le côté rpg c'est à
dire quand vous tuer des ennemis vous
gagnez des ormes donc des points avec
lesquels vous pouvez acheter des objets
par exemple une norme qui vous fait
revivre quand vous m'en vais avait là
les orbes rouges là que je vais gagner
c'est ce qui permet d'acheter donc ces
fameux objet par exemple d'acheter une
norme qui vous fait revivre d'acheter
des choses qui vous redonne de la vie et
puis voilà et de l'eau what the fuck
temps c'est énorme ce genre de truc que
j'adore vraiment dans le jeu c'est
simplement excellent salut toi comment
ça va et on pourrait aussi en fait on va
avoir des points d'amélioration qui on
tue des animaux souvent des points
d'amélioration et ses points
d'amélioration vont nous permettre de
débloquer des nouvelles techniques
voyez là par exemple j'en ai deux je
vais vous montrer objets non c'est pas
dans l'objet a il faut que je croise une
statue au temps pour moi il faut que je
croise une statue donc dragon un peu mon
devoir croiser d'ici pas très longtemps
pour améliorer le tout est donc avec ses
poings de coubon pour améliorer ou même
avoir de nouvelles de nouveaux combos
disponibles avec telle ou telle arme
c'est sélectif par exemple avec aux eris
donc la peau avec la hache ou alors avec
l'épée et même avec les pistolets moi
j'ai surtout amélioré aux eris pour le
moment parce que c'est vraiment un truc
que j'adore tout simplement j'adore et
enfin voila c'est vraiment un peu chacun
se repère avec avec son arme ça dépend
son style de jeu ça c'est plus en finale
j'ai grandement circulaire ça c'est plus
buzz buzz truc super lent et ça c'est
l'intervalle entre les deux des trucs
assez rapide à épiloguer quoi on peut
faire des trucs books par exemple à
tomber sur soi même comme ça ou au cou
bref donc voilà c'est un peu le système
rpg du jeu avec les avec donc les fameux
point qu'on a à force de tuer des
ennemis et c'est assez fou bon je pense
que qu'on les a tous on obtient un
gameplay assez très très très variés et
honnêtement moi qui joue rarement des
jeux du genre j'ai vachement du mal de
varier entre les armes de me repérer
dans les tournées alors là c'est deux
portes y avait du rouge dessus c'est que
je pouvais la casse et qu'avec mon h
tout comme tout à l'heure et demie oui
oh là là mais 4 mais dégage mec
parfois ils sont un peu bête mais ça n'a
pas souvent à l'épée en fait j'ai
remarqué je suis plutôt qu'il a utilisé
la photo ou la chaire j'aime pas trop
les paies iphone clé en argent dont la
journée à quai en argent que l'on trouve
dans les niveaux
alors je disais donc il ya différents
types de portes qu'on peut casser soit
l'âge soit avec le l'afo qui sont
parfois plus ou moins cachés derrière
dans les niveaux et qui nous amène à
avec enfin qui nous a menés dans une
salle en fait tout par exemple il y aura
un monde dénier à tuer un certain temps
il y aura enfin voilà des choses du
genre alors une porte où il faut le
reflet des choses du truc du genre
pardon pas du truc c'est un peu comme
bien d'autres par exemple là on peut
aller là où alors non à la 55e et donc
voilà enfin bref c'est un gameplay assez
sympa et variés pour ceux qui sont pas
trop fan du genre jeu à voilà la fameuse
statue si je vous conseille franchement
pour vous déchaînez ou quoi puis
l'histoire est très très très plongeant
entendant les revenir dans l'histoire
est quand même très très plongeante
amélioration voilà donc on peut soit
capacités donc ça c'est par exemple pour
les esquives pour faire des couteaux des
coups de poing ah ouais c'est quand même
ses biens propres
ou alors on peut ici a dit faire des
nouvelles techniques avec l'épée boxe à
quoi on va booster les paie un peu ça
fait longtemps
pourtant j'étais bloqué toutes les
techniques ou alors avant avant les
grecs ça je n'ai jamais fait encore
regardé petites images ça a l'air bien
portant basse salaire énorme spirale
mortelle
ouais bah voilà s'agit pas appris grand
chose
rt et grecs y pose y on va faire ça ça a
l'air sympa comme truc secousses ont la
chute on l' élan rt plus avant avant y
ou à fougères bon on va essayer tout ça
comme objet on va pouvoir acheter à bâle
nord pour ressusciter simplement sont
noirs et puis voilà alors c'est quoi
c'était avant avant
ah c'est ça ben ah ok d'accord ça envoie
des espèces de converser sur les
araignées j'ai dit on va essayer sur les
araignées
après ça a l'air efficace voilà on
continue [ __ ] l'espèce d'estomac de
gaulle oui un peu pour ça naruto ou ça
pue le boss ou bordel je n'aime pas trop
ça alors là on va le monde des vivants
envoyés à travers ça c'est là là on a
juste une petite vision vite du monde
des vivants donc on voit les gens qui
voient là les canettes tranquillement
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc quoi oh
la vache
dieu on dirait un peu le mec dans star
wars là le gros java n'empêche à vassy
java choix
ok d'accord donc il boite le vomi de
java qu'est ce qui fait donc là c'est
kate cat ou quoi combler comme vous
voulez qui nous guide
désormais c'est la médiane [ __ ] la
voie était en anglais je crois une
petite erreur alors on va essayer un peu
j'ai des manières tout ça bamba vrai on
peut vraiment me laisser les ennemis en
l'air super longtemps ça à ça ça fait
mal
oh j'ai fait un truc mais tellement cons
on va plutôt à tirer c'est vrai que j'ai
toujours tendance à aller peut-il
ranimer samoa c'est moins risqué de les
attirer up laisse qui dit que d'aller
vers eux alors hop un peu de faire des
combos connu ensuite on peut aussi le
leur et attire avec le grappin une fois
que kiel en l'air c'est à six tués à 8
on va se marrer ici parce que y aller
destruction que le à yanji beau milieu
d'un parterre j'aime pas trop le vomi de
javale mcgee mauvais mais pète alors on
va lever pop a ha il m'aide sherbatov a
on va se battre on va se battre on va se
barrer on m'a tiré un aède je me dis
[ __ ] les relous tiens tiens tiens
alors on va lui faire sa fête mais alors
là mais quand je suis dans les parcs
soit peut-être revient la casse toi
c'est tellement temps des qs des fois
non pourtant alors il ya cet hymne aux
difficultés dans le jeu je dois être en
mode normal de biya facile normal et
très dur et je suis juste en normal
quel point de cogedim alors le boss aux
noms et aux x 2 sort des phrases je vous
jure
comment on va faire pour est passé au
dessus
et ce qui peut rentrer dans son pote
pour le charme al wafa quoi bon se
déchaînent alors bien la matière en
parure et bien là à les gros gros mais
bon comment [ __ ] [ __ ] mais c'est
grave dure correction deux nantais
grosses fesses de fatou faut vraiment
tapé dans ces faits sinon c'est lui
faire un du tout il en arrive à faire
les petits coins allez allez allez allez
à je veux te voir même pas qui m'a
découdre face au gardien l'armée de
passe
face à metz et charles vos médias bapt
indus qu'on doit tout en bugey
tu vas autres
o o j'avais jamais fait ça on peut faire
tomber aussi génial c'est que quand il
est dos donc comme ça au génial mais
c'est génial sérieux à la vous devez
vous dire ma pipe est un cas point l'a
juste fait tomber un râteau et des
grossesses on est sérieux on peut faire
tomber comme ça là à merde allez bien
bien voilà alors qu'au niveau de la
bande sont là ce que vous entendez cdu
sont eux de combi christ
ah merde du coup j'ai fait tout cela
c'est justement de combi crise
alors il ya soit du métal soit du
dubstep et honnêtement quand ans dans
une battle était à cette chanson qui se
met en route et je peux dire que tu es
vraiment content c'est vraiment un truc
2 août et la tête un terrain d'entente
incertain hier c'est à attaquer comme
c'est vraiment énorme surtout n'ose y
alors là c'est le comble crise qui
s'activait mais quand c'est le noyage
projet moi je suis plus d'obstacles que
et quand c'est le nose ya honnêtement
c'est juste de la prime vraiment de la
bvk face entraînant ses membres et voilà
bref vous devez vous dire tahar messaoud
flightcare du koweït mais honnêtement
j'ai vraiment kiffé je trouve pas
vraiment de défaut sûrement parce que
j'ai pas encore indiqué guy quel jeu
donc je peux pas vraiment vous dire même
si c'est l'apéritif ou quoi toute
manière c'est un beat them all donc je
pense que c'est répétitif mais là ça
déjà ça fait l'armée chant c'était juste
un gros c'est ça qui est énorme c'est
dans le tessin personnage qui est
vachement modeste 1 toujours modeste
alors du coup comment va venir à bout de
ce gros truc gluant bien moche je me le
demande
alors est ce que c'est la fin du stage
oui fin du stage je vais pouvoir me
montrer un petit peu comment ça se passe
donc un stage chez un niveau il ya 20
niveaux score final donc là le score
final sera établi en fonction du temps
qu'on a mis des points de style et et de
l'achèvement s'ajuste pas trop ce que
c'est l'achèvement en août est d'accord
donc ça nous donne des points objets
utilisés d'accord donc ça pénalise j'ai
la lettre à
je crois que le mac ça doit être qui
plus est je pense bonus de mission on a
eu des points en plus et des compétences
aussi en plus belle dans le magasin
objets on va acheter quoi on va en
acheter on va tout simplement aidé en
amélioration va améliorer les gueules
j'ai jamais rien amélioré hogan ricochet
maintenez puis relâché x
faire ça déluge à +6 sympathique
s'adjuge 1 versée à plus exposé sol
d'accord très bien aussi dangereux en
fait c'est surtout un truc où c'est la
personnalisation du personnage qui qui
importe c'est à dire le style genre donc
il ya 20 dlc la dent dans la dans
l'édition collector j'ai pris 200
collector je sais pas si eux s'ils
apportent des skins ou des nouvelles
armes ou quoi c'est le pas que samurai
donc je pense qu'il ya quand même des
nouvelles armes mais mais qu'est ce que
j'ai fait moi commencer bien commencé
mais mais en tout cas je sais pas ce qui
n'a pas pu en tout cas je sais que c'est
plutôt le skin du personnage qui est
très important par rapport à ces dégâts
ou quoi puisque de manière les dégâts on
les a en fonction bas de des compétences
et tout mais sur le xbox live y aura des
choses disponible en vente donc pour
quelques points microsoft par exemple un
nouveau skin de hdp une nouvelle veste
ou je sais pas trop j'ai pas encore été
voir parce que je ne suis plus un
abonnement xbox live mais j'irai voir et
puis je vous en direz des nouvelles
vous me gêner si vous voulez que je
fasse une idée sur ce jeu là c'était un
peu pour introduire le jeu c'est pour ça
que je parle à cent à l'heure et je vous
dis tout ça et vous me direz et je vous
dirai tout simplement
et puis pour ceux que ça intéresse non
il ya le making of un peu du du jeu où
il ya des ya des acteurs qui témoigne un
ca c ur est tout simplement un trailer
assez épique avec la fameuse bande son
de mauzac énorme bon bref les
annotations une façon de vous avez vu la
vidéo
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel un
univers tellement bizarre commenge de sa
part je peux pas de figure c'est quoi un
minuteur
c'est une fiole
pour boucler la comme je vous ai dit
j'ai pas besoin de savoir tu sautes je
tourne t sérieuse c'est moi confiance
avec la musique qui se met à trop stylé
hockey du bon salle tout
donc olala génial donc comme je vous ai
dit toujours dans la modestie arrêt
d'accord ok d'accord on un timer ok
alors qu'est ce qui te fait pense pas
qu'on oblige les truites manière mais on
va quand même le faire oh [ __ ] à je
déteste on a quand même un timer
on va essayer quand même de tuer
quelques mois ça serait pas trop mal sur
femme armée mais revoit la question
allait au fond sur 30 ans
il ya des grappins il ya des grappins
hop hop beaucoup il est gras pense à
bosua merde merde
olalala voilà comme je suis nul c'est
juste qu'ils ont fait pour faire un saut
de l'ange voilà tac wa de justesse un
homme qui sont tellement faibles cela en
fait à
si la presse patrick
aussi non au niveau un petit truc aussi
je vis au niveau du prix du jeu qui m'a
fait halluciner écoute je sais qu'à au
chant le jeu est à 45 euros ce qui est
rien honnêtement pour un jeune noble par
rapport aux 70 euros notamment de call
of de pas mal de dieu en toute manière
je trouve que c'est un petit peu comme
du foutage de gueule de payer 70 euros
pour un jeu et on nous a fait ici un
petit clin d'oeil en mode web à regarder
nous ne jouissons pas si cher que ça 45
euros à auchan donc pour venir mais
sinon je crois que c'est 55 euros le
terrestre entre guillemets normale dans
par exemple micromania games a fait
faillite d'air j'étais choquée je m'y
attendais tellement pas je pensais que
ça marchait bien et tout est comme quoi
que amazon et tout ça au maire que je me
dépêche
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] je vais pas la
voir ces morts un coco pour casser vous
classe imoca c'est vite vite vite vite
tac tac tac ceyrac allez allez allez 5
chat croit deux halls alors l'oeil de
justesse de la vache j'ai pas fait gaffe
mais c'est vrai que c'est dur quand même
deux
waouh
- what the fuck la 22 sec 11
oh là là mais quel homme
un tunnel avec des la lumière au bout ça
pue du cul ça pue à part non en même
temps il ya un peu du vomi de java ya
lavage qu'on va
à
ouah c'est un boss hockey et un boss
super g pas dans la merde [ __ ] wa mon
bal boss ce sera la fin de la vidéo
j'aimerais bien le défenseur à soueich
ok boss voit la vache
alors attendez plus juste roulette russe
a on peut aller la voir on va aller là
haut up
vas-y peut taper ça ouais on l'a vu une
fois ok
ce à quoi bon un [ __ ] vaches on se met
en mode avec la hache non ah non ok nans
pas du viol
[Musique]
les gars
tiens bon la défense et la barbe tient
up
ok donc en fait pour but et rouge qu'il
a au milieu du front
en fait ma carte change et plates thomas
schaaf ont beaucoup
merde et vomir
c'est un ska pop d'accord ok j'ai
compris la technique et la partie
multiples
ok là en france mais ça tient la merde
merde
pour nous
ce qu'il fait là et oh
ok en fait je peux attaquer annoncé lui
fait rien
non
dans la bâche sur lequel on glisse on
prend je ne sais vraiment pas ce que ça
vaut lui enlever un quart de sa vie
allait je t'attends vient à ok ouais on
peut pas d'accord ok up
ok d'accord donc en fait on peut lui
péter lema comme ça
ah ouais ok d'accord
ça va trois produits qu'on veut en fait
waouh aulas va choquer c'est tellement
risqué jamais
heil
car d'habitude
la vache je me casse non oh oh [ __ ]
merde quoi je suis tombé la saison 20
victoires 22 fait perdre 10 kilos moche
voilà dans tes objets dans tes dents tu
es donc
[Musique]
ah voilà juste faire le bois genre à
laisser voilà comme ça
alors qu'on balta main
à
[Musique]
ok on y retourne
mais des boues tellement moche lycée ok
donc le soukouss elle le fait elle
vraiment large plus mal que ça
amédée par terre allez au revoir ça lui
est là il ya des gros monstres
d'ici la tête
et c'est dans un gobelet
par jusqu'à ce la vache
ouais ça va ensuite il n'est pas très
très dur une fois que tu as contexte rue
c'est un peu genre satisfait mais on
fera bien partie de quoi être pas de
surcoût gothard
à
[Applaudissements]
taman shaker à la carotte est ici
avec la petite phrase à nouvelles armes
ah oui j'ai oublié dire qu'on débloque
des armes fur à mesure du jeu
orgie nouvelle arme j'ai des points trop
cool et